- [Narrator] See Paige.
See Paige play.
Play, Paige, pl--
What the hell is Paige playing?
This is an orchestra
comprised entirely of flutes.
This works because flutes
can cover the entire range
of an orchestra on their own,
from the piccolo at the
top (piccolo whistles),
all the way to the double contrabass flute
down at the bottom (double
contrabass flute booms).
Very cool.
And there's Paige playing,
you know, back from the intro.
- I'm Paige Long, and I'm
a professional flutist.
- [Narrator] Wait, flutist or flautist?
- I like flutist.
- [Narrator] She's one of
a handful of people playing
the three largest flutes
in the flute family:
the contrabass flute,
the subcontrabass flute,
and the double contrabass flute.
Let's learn about big flutes.
- [Paige] In its case, the
double contrabass flute weighs
approximately 30 pounds.
It stands over eight feet tall,
and it's 22 feet of tubing.
The subcontrabass flute in
G has 11 feet of tubing,
and the contrabass in
C has 9 feet of tubing.
- [Narrator] So, how does
one play an instrument
with 22 feet of tubing?
- [Paige] For these lower flutes,
it's a whole different technique.
Your embouchure is looser--
- [Narrator] New word!
Embouchure.
Em-bou-chure.
- [Paige] Embouchure is the
way you shape your mouth
to make a sound on the flute.
Your mouth is looser,
bigger, takes a lot more air,
and a lot more support.
I feel like I've run a 10k
when I'm done with a concert.
- [Narrator] 'Cause it's hard
to get a clean, low sound?
- [Paige] They actually play
the lowest possible notes
of an orchestral instrument.
- [Narrator] Say, lowest of
any orchestral instrument?
Now what does that mean?
Hey, guys, can you help us out here?
- [Man] Well, alright.
Ready, boys?
♪ The double contrabass flute goes low ♪
♪ Lower than any instrument can go ♪
♪ Lower than the string
bass, that big old guy ♪
♪ He makes that bass line fly ♪
- [Narrator] And what's next?
- [Man] It's the subcontrabass flute!
Hit it!
♪ Another big flute
sounds like a bassoon ♪
♪ The subcontrabass can carry a tune ♪
♪ The contrabass flute
is the smallest fellow ♪
♪ It sounds just like a cello ♪
- [Narrator] Wow, thanks!
Now I understand.
So Paige, what do you like
about these giant flutes?
- [Paige] In the land of flutes,
they're like the subculture
of the flute community.
And we provide a role that
the concert flute cannot.
- [Narrator] It all checks out.
Paige, play us out.
(flute trio plays)